John kick us off with your even McGregor
impression Oh
I'm even Ewan McGregor I'm from Scotland
and mi was in train splitting and also
I'm obi-wan and I've got a very boyish
tone in my voice and when I do an
American accent I say I can't do
American human but I can attempt
slightly Scottish Ewan McGregor was you
like say they're hoping it would be good
enough for someone could deep fake even
McGregor's face onto you but that's not
gonna happen
hey we're gonna watch Ewan McGregor's
obi-wan Kenobi an original Star Wars
trilogy deep fake this comes from the
channel Luke I don't know about you guys
but I've been down my wormholes of deep
fake videos up late at night toward high
prefer shallow fakes but guys I get it
this show still happening in 2023
oh my god original Star Wars trilogy
using depicting great shading beard
wow that's great
the ears are pretty big but no that is
incredible Wow
you mean yeah like this shine on his
forehead goodness go yeah we done dude
that was great that was yeah that was
like eerie yeah is weird because it's
like you know and especially on the
side-by-side what Alec Guinness is
supposed to look like but then you see
you in and it's like a combo and it
bends your mind for a hot second because
it is his face but mixed with yeah Alec
Guinness his ears yeah it looks very
natural like you said though I said
actually shading I bought it and then
you kind of caught that from my
brainwaves well that's usually the
biggest thing is like sometimes in the
moving shots and a different kind of
lighting it might not match as well as
like the earlier moments but majority of
this looked pretty flawless like
especially has the hood on and they're
talking to the stormtrooper that was my
favorite yeah that just looks so real
and it really makes you hope they do get
that show off the ground yeah because I
always thought it would be really cool
to see obi-wan Kenobi slowly evolve into
Ben Kenobi to the point where he kind of
loses a little bit of sight of his past
life because if you really pay attention
to that first moment that he's like
obi-wan Kenobi no no that's the name
I've not
oh it is like a loss of identity at the
point like oh wow that's right I used to
be this guy so I've always wanted to see
like that evolution that transformation
of what took place there and watching
this footage just makes you go man
watching him evolve into old man Kenobi
he would be so great this is what some
of the best deep fake footage of it I've
ever seen I've seen a lot of well beyond
that I got I'm telling ya this is the
easiest wormhole for me to go down oh
yeah you can just entertain like so many
families yeah that you've always had
about casting and things like that and
you can meme out you know yeah which
other ones has he done oh yeah no I've
definitely seen these I've definitely
seen some of these oh yeah you know he's
Smith this guy's gotta kind of blow what
he does so subscribe - a MOOC as soon as
you can
thanks for being here people it's fun to
laugh sometimes may the force be with
you
you